this offer is a walking talking
soundboard another threadable is only
for the commercials or can you actually
drink them in addition to being one of
the coin flippiest snipers in the
history of Cs go Alexi ALU yali is known
for singing very very weird literally
every time a microphone just enters his
General vicinity I think we should ban
nuke
to be honest I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding I have to get some words for you
about this young player he is a Monster
yeah and while he isn't gracing major
finals anymore homie will go down in
history as the closest thing
Counter-Strike has ever seen to a
walking talking skull emoji anyways
uh